this week on history on book TV
Einstein's clocks Wonka raised maps
author Peter Galison recounts the dual
attempt by the two scientists to
synchronize clocks during the end of the
19th century the program lasts about an
hour 15 minutes good evening I'm Bob
Cavanaugh I'm the director of the Oakley
Center for Humanities and Social
Sciences and it's my pleasure to welcome
all of you and to introduce this year's
Richmond the lectures speaker Peter
Galison who was the Mallinckrodt
professor of the history of science and
of physics at Harvard University the
Richmond lectures were established by
Don Richmond a longtime professor of
mathematics at Williams with the goal of
bringing to campus distinguished
scholars who hold broad humanistic
interests in the history or philosophy
of science note no doubt Peter Galison
is precisely the kind of person Don
Richmond had in mind when he established
these lectures professor galliston is a
summa [ __ ] laude graduate of Harvard
majoring in the history of science who
went on to receive an MPhil from
Cambridge University in the history and
philosophy of science and then back to
Harvard to complete his doctoral work in
both physics and history of science he
is a prolific author whose work explores
the interaction of experimentation
instrumentation and theory in 20th
century physics his 1997 book image and
logic was awarded the Pfizer prize for
best book in the history of science and
his recently published book and also the
title of this lecture
Einstein's clocks and Poincare his maps
has received very impressive reviews
professor Galton is the recipient of
many many honors including the Max
Planck research award for international
cooperation in 1999 and a MacArthur
Fellowship in 1997 he's a fellow of the
American Physical Society and the
American Association for the Advancement
of science and a member of the
scientific advisory board of the Max
Planck Institute in his research that
brought him to the topic he discussed
tonight professor galliston discovered
both Einstein and Bukhari approached the
problem of relativity by first
confronting the practical issue of
accurate time measurement and clock
synchronization this places Einstein's
theory in a very unique context in a
very practical one
Einstein spent seven formative years in
the Patent Office in Bern Switzerland
learning about the need of modern rail
systems to establish accurate times over
large distances when carry both a
mathematician animal astronomer was also
working on the problem of relativity and
like Einstein grounded his work in the
practical problems he confronted his
president of the French board of
longitude in that position his goal was
to create an accurate global map and
coordinated clocks were integral to his
endeavor we are very pleased that
professor galliston can be with us
tonight to talk about this very
interesting work and I'd ask you to join
me in welcoming to the first time at
Williams College
thank you all
thanks for the very nice introduction
Bob it's a pleasure to be here tonight I
want to speak about time about the
coordination of clocks and how this very
simple problem setting one o'clock to
say the same time as another lay central
to practical philosophical and physical
concerns that helps change the face of
science in the early 20th century
Einstein when he came to think back on
his life not long before his death wrote
a kind of autobiographical note and in
that note he was discussing what kind of
work he had done the kinds of thoughts
he'd had and suddenly he broke off this
rather formal address to speak with an
intense intimacy as if directly to
Newton he said Newton forgive me Newton
FETs I meow you did as much as anyone
could have done in the time that you did
and yeah an Einstein essentially asked
him to forgive him for having overthrown
the centerpiece of Newton's view of
absolute space and absolute time my
interest in this problem goes back quite
a long way it had never made sense to me
that Einstein was working six days a
week with extraordinary energy at the
Patent Office and that during the most
productive years of his life this had
nothing to do with what he was actually
doing that it seemed implausible to
think that this highly technical work on
electricity and magnetism new forms of
dynamos had nothing at all to do with
the revolution that he helped
precipitate in the physical sciences but
I didn't quite know how to get at the
problem and then one day I was standing
in a train station in northern Europe
looking up and down the station rather
bored and I noticed that the clocks were
all had read the same there minute hands
were all in the same place on the clocks
I thought they made good clocks back
then and then I noticed that the second
hands were marching exactly in sync and
I thought these aren't good clocks these
clocks are synchronized their wires
underneath this station bringing these
clocks in
to alignment and then thinking about
Einstein's first paper on relativity
which he begins by talking about how you
coordinate clocks on train stations I
began to wonder if maybe Einstein had
noticed something like this a hundred
years ago so I went back to the United
States was and began poking around the
papers of the Swiss Patent Office the
patents that had been taken out and
found that there was an immense industry
in coordinated clocks for trains and at
the center of that industry had been
Switzerland and all the patents there
had had to go to the Swiss Patent Office
and that's in the sense where I begin
this story trying to figure out what
Einstein was doing with clocks both
practically and theoretically and what
probably his greatest competitor was
doing a man not nearly so well known as
that best known person of the 20th
century Albert Einstein a Frenchman only
quark of a known and venerated by
mathematicians today but perhaps less
well known to the general public but
that was not at all so back at the turn
of the century
Huang Cray was a person of extraordinary
reputation he had transformed
mathematics in a country that worships
mathematics as no other he had changed
the face of philosophy his philosophical
books were bestsellers read across
France and were exemplars of high
literary style that eventually set
Quandt gray at the head not only of the
scientific Academy of France but also of
its literary one in addition to that
Quan Chi served at the highest levels of
French Third Republic Administration
this is a country that then and now sets
its more academically inclined
administrators up to the very highest
reaches of power he was cousin to the
President of the Republic he was on some
of the leading commissions he headed the
bureau of longitude which is a
prestigious body it's concerned not only
with scientific matters but with very
practical ones of which much more in a
moment but more to the point prawn Cray
was a consummate physicist as well as
mathematician and he came up with many
of the same equations and much of the
understanding of relativity that
Einstein did from an enormous Lee
different perspective what I want to do
tonight is not to review the entirety of
the
history of relativity that's a story
much longer story but to focus in
particular on this very simple idea
answering the question what do we mean
when we say it's seven o'clock over
there how do we coordinate our clocks in
this I want in a sense to read both
literally and metaphorically to say that
when Einstein talks in his paper about
the coordination of clocks on train
stations and down train tracks that
maybe just maybe he means in addition to
everything else the coordination of
clocks on train stations and that maybe
when Prager I tells us in his
introduction to this subject that what
he means by the exchange
is the exchange of time signals by
telegraphers trying to map the world
that maybe just maybe it's got something
to do with telegraphers exchanging
signals to map the world but in addition
to those literal meanings there's also a
metaphorical meaning and the methods
that they developed upon Crais and
Einstein for coordinating clocks became
exemplars for what it meant to do
science not only relativity but physics
in general in fact when Heisenberg and
Bohr the other quantum mechanician x'
began to think about what they would do
in their quantum mechanics revolution 20
years later the example that they held
before their eyes of what to do about
ideas like causality determinism was to
model it on einstein's analysis of how
to understand time coordination when the
philosopher Quine one of the best-known
philosophers in the anglo-american world
of the last century came to say what he
thought about the basic notions that we
have of the world he said that
everything must be revisable mathematics
science logic language but he said the
last thing that will revise the thing we
will hold on to longest before giving up
is einstein's idea of how to coordinate
clocks so this idea of clock
coordination stands in fields in physics
and other domains of physics in
philosophy as a model of what proper
knowledge of our world
might be let me start then with plonk
Ray Walker I began as a young man of an
extraordinary talent in mathematics was
evident by the time he started
publishing in mathematics when he was 17
or 18 years old he went to Ecole
Polytechnique a school which is for
Americans a bit hard to understand a
kind of hybrid between MIT and West
Point a military institution whose
graduates were gone to high levels in
the militaries in France and had since
the time of Napoleon
its scientific graduates had transformed
astronomy mathematics physics and it had
oscillated during its career back and
forth between an institution designed to
train the highest level of pure science
and the administrators of French Empire
the people who ran France in its
internal structure and its military
force parkerich came to Polytechnique
shortly after the disaster for the
French of the franco-prussian war in
1870 71 the French had been soundly
defeated by the Germans and the French
blamed their scientists and their
scientific trainings in part for this
defeat the Germans ability to mobilize
vast arrays of trains under the
leadership of General von Moltke was
seen to be part of a vast
infrastructural advantage that the
Germans held the Prussians held over the
French and so there was a huge effort to
bolster the French scientific training
and none came in for more reformist
effort than Ecole Polytechnique when
they began that reform effort it was
decided that the pure scientific and the
pure engineering should be merged
together in a kind of flat surface with
neither one being dominated by the other
and so for at least a brief moment in
the years after 1870 the goal was to
train engineers with a high level of
scientific competence and highly trained
scientists with a great deal of
engineering understanding that's when
ponca ray arrived and he began to
understand the world through this
combination of pure scientific and
engineering expertise so while he was
training to become
and one of the clearly becoming one of
the leading mathematicians in France he
was also training to be a mining
engineer and in fact when he graduated
he went to inspect mines a kind of
disaster inspector something like what
an NTSB inspector does after a plane
crash he would go down into mines
sometimes while they were still burning
after a methane explosion and try to
figure out what had caused the problem
and how it could be remedied to make
other mines safer here's on this first
slide you'll see a map that he drew to
send to his parents in one of his first
mining expeditions wonk ray as we'll see
when he fate was faced with a problem
mapped everything you can see in the in
the upper left there a map of
Scandinavia and his travels see the
little boat as he began to in the hunt
for various for various sites to mine
and and then in the lower right-hand you
see a little map which I've blown up
below it which is his happiness in times
normal that's the solid line in in
trains that's the dotted line in pluses
yesterday evening and right now in the
dotted line that exists on the bottom he
plotted the course of his colds when he
got sick he plotted his mathematics he
plotted his physics this was a man who
knew his maps when he went down into a
mine one of the greatest disasters that
he experienced an explosion that
traumatized him for the rest of his life
in fact the last publication that he
issued one that was actually printed
after his death included in the coroner
a little symbol which is hard to read
but what it is is a Davy lamp a mining
safety lamp and he remembered it for his
entire career because this is one of the
first things he did was to descend into
a mine it at the at the minds of mine ye
after a huge explosion there were bodies
everywhere some of the people were still
living but tremendously badly injured
and Parker I drew this map to try to
track down what had happened following
the air flows along the tunnels even
they began this investigation even while
the flames were still burning an
eventual
we tracked it down to a mining lantern a
single Lantern number 476 with a dent in
it that he figured out had been hit by a
miners pickaxe by accident opening up a
crevasse in the lamp and allowing the
flame inside to ignite the methane
around it but Parker at the same time
was also interested in more abstract
problems he was interested in
understanding one of the great
outstanding mathematical problems of his
day namely whether the universe was
stable whether the solar system would
continue to run as it had or whether
this the planets would fly off to
infinity or crash into the Sun he wrote
the paper and invented a new method of
thinking about these problems in other
word he imagined a sheet of the Blue
Square that you see up in the left in
which the orbits would crash through it
making dots each time it came through
and then you could picture an
understanding of how those dots behaved
did they converge to a point did they
diverge how did it work in other words
he was able to forget about the detailed
orbits of the planets and simply look at
the pattern that they punctured in this
imaginary paper these have become now
known now as pong Kure maps and
understanding them became a tool that he
used to try to crack this problem of the
stability of the universe he decided
that the universe was stable this was a
man of the establishment he was pleased
to show that the planets would remain in
their proper orbits and he put as a
title for his essay as a title quotation
that the Stars shall remain in their
place
always well he won an immense prize that
was given out under the name of the king
of Sweden Oscar the second and he was
celebrated the issue of the journal was
published under his friend and supporter
he's been sent out to everybody and then
the copy editors sent to him a little
note that said dear professor pong cray
I just have one small problem you
examine all these different cases but
there's one case that you seem to have
left out I'm sure it'll just take a
minute to add something about it and the
editors wrote a note saying too that he
expected this would be a matter of a
moment please just fill in the blank and
will corrected and proofs and plonker I
went silent
and then wrote back and said I'm afraid
what has happened here is not a small
error it has unraveled the whole of my
paper in in fine and in gross the paper
is incorrect it needs to be written from
start to finish and he began that
process frantically rewriting that was
all very well except the journal had
already been circulated to every
important mathematician in Europe and
then the the admit when the head of the
journal got wind of this in frantic and
fearful tones wrote to each of the
mathematicians who would receive the
advance copies and said there's a small
atom that we have to add to the paper
please leave the copy or copy off with
the maid downstairs will pick it up
don't worry we'll have it back to you in
a moment they gathered these all up they
were buried carefully only a few
survived but want Cray did rewrite the
paper and in the course of which he
transformed the field of nonlinear
dynamics and created what we now known
as cat now know as chaos theory in which
the plonker a Maps didn't converge or
diverge in the usual way but seemed to
go way out of control in ways that were
not even visualizable but again typical
for up want Cray attacking a problem
whether it's a cold or his happiness on
the train whether it's his travels
whether it's an understanding of the
universe whatever it is make a map and
figure out how to understand it with a
kind of physical intuition joined to a
ferocious desire to understand as Parker
I advanced up his career ladder he
became he was brought he lived through
some of the times when the French were
trying to establish the meter in a much
broader framework back at the time of
the French Revolution the French had
introduced the metre is a form of
rationality which would be a symbol of
the new revolutionary order and the
kilogram that would unify in a practical
way the weights and measures all over
France but more than that it was a
rational understanding of the world a
decimal system of the world that will
hold no truck with the older forms
of arbitrary measurements of weights and
measures so they began to impose this
but it didn't catch on very much until a
century later around 1875 there was a
convention of the meter and a drive now
in the new French Republic that had
grown up after the Third Republic that
grew up after the French defeat to the
Prussians and the meter became a symbol
of this revived sense of rationality and
a revival of the old ambitions of the
revolution itself so in the revolution
if instance they tried to decimal eyes
the week into 10 days which had the
particular virtue of eliminating Sundays
for anti-clerical lists this was added
delight they had even tried to
rationalize in decimal eyes the clock
and go from 1 to 10 instead of 1 to 12
so there was a real effort to put this
on a rational footing all of this had
been given up in a deal with the church
but the kilogram and the meter were the
first to be revived and in 1875 that
began and elaborate machines were built
like this one one of my favorite
machines ever called a universal
comparator which takes a meter the DA
meter and known as M and put it on one
side and that it would inscribe another
length of special alloy on the other and
it would inscribe an exact meter there
this was the meter M and the kilogram K
that sat at the center of this system
and they became then the occasion for
the gathering of delegates from all over
the world to have a ceremonial burying
of the meter and in this ceremonial
burying this K you see at the centre
here surrounded by its witnesses late a
moi which would testify but what
happened to their bodies what happened
to K were anything untoward to happen
like a fire were bad conditions down in
the vault and then this was to be triple
walked the meter is in that upper casing
there triple locked secured everything
was going very well with the planet
potenti areas from all the countries of
the world when it was realized that they
were missing one of the keys and the
French said oh no problem we'll have the
Minister of the Interior will come and
the key and the delegate said absolutely
not all ceremonies will stop until the
foreign minister comes we will not speak
to the interior minister because this is
no longer French territory this vault is
in no country the metre which is the
most specific and most precisely
designed object ever created is going to
rise to become the most universal object
on earth and it is located the place
that's below Paris and yet nowhere in
France this was in some way as the
ambition of the Third Republic to be
both French and universal an ambition
when my dad that has not been lost in
the process of trying to universalize
and spread the weights and measures
there was also an attempt to spread time
and the first system for spreading time
is a wonder of Victorian technology in
this picture you see the centre command
post for sending time through tubes of
compressed air underneath the streets of
Paris so with an enormous puff of
compressed air a time signal would be
sent from this clock that you see on the
right pumped through these pipes and
delivered all over Paris you could buy
your clock at this this is a retail
store that celled compressed air
controlled coordinated clocks what the
Statue of Liberty is doing there I
cannot tell you but you would buy one of
these clocks and put it in your store or
in your house if you were wealthy enough
and then when it received this puff of
air your clock would reset to 12 o'clock
at one o'clock or two o'clock as was
appropriate and when these coordinated
clocks were set up around Paris they
were objects of great admiration as you
see people here admiring this at the
plus limit then and they were symbols of
modernity this was a salient technology
the way a computer would have done in
the post-war period or in 1960 a rocket
ship or a personal computer in 1983
these were not ordinary technologies
when you go on the street and you see a
coordinated clock we're not impressed
they practically fade into the
background but then they were signs of
modernity in fact remember in the mid
19th century most clocks didn't have
minute hands must last less
second hands so clocks they were
coordinated to 1015 seconds of precision
had the effect that a clock like the old
Bulova digital clock would have had when
it was first set up in the 1960s in next
to Penn Station this was a mark of
precision of modernity and exactitude
this is a map of the plant the
distribution of these pipes of the
pumping of time and I should say one
second before I lose that image is that
this in a country in a world where time
had not been kept to any accuracy at all
suddenly being able to pump time across
Paris seemed very remarkable but very
quickly people began to realize that it
took 15 20 seconds to get across Paris
and suddenly from not having minute
hands they began to say well wait a
second
R&D smo is getting its time 20 seconds
late why should that be we ought to
start correcting for it we need in order
to coordinate clocks to take account of
the time it takes a signal to get from
one place to another this is a theme to
which we will return but at the same
time a much more modern and ambitious
attempt was being made to make
electrically distributed time after all
the Telegraph was all the rage being
installed alongside trains and
throughout the countries of Europe
across the oceans into the United States
and one of the ways that the Americans
had perfected for sending time was to
send a signal and then have it move a
seismograph like object which would make
a little blip when that when the signal
arrived as you see at the bottom here so
very precise signals could be made in
fact when cables were first wired under
the Atlantic Ocean just after the Civil
War one of the very first things that
were done was to send an electrical
signal why because to make a map of the
world to understand the basic ideas of
mapping which would tell the vastly
increased amount of shipping where they
would encounter shoals and so on one had
to be able to have maps of latitude and
longitude latitude is easy you just look
at where the North Pole the North Star
is it
right above you here at the North Pole
if it's at the equator you're at the
equator if it's in between you can judge
where you are rather easily if the earth
wasn't spinning on its axis longitude
would be just as simple you'd take a map
of the Stars you'd look up see what star
you were under and you'd know what
longitude you're at the problem is the
earth is spinning on its axis and so the
Stars that are right above you keep
changing so in order to know how far you
are east and west from a fixed point you
need to know what stars are above some
fixed point like Paris or London and
then know how far you are at that time
in other words you need to know
simultaneity that was fine in Europe or
on other land accessible places you
could send the signal along telegraph
wires but across the ocean that wasn't
possible and even after even in the time
of the civil war indeed even in the
1890s it wasn't there was still
disagreement about the longitudinal
difference between the new world and the
old and so coordinating by the extent
exchange of signals of telegraph signals
became a vital matter for that longitude
so if you were sailing to Brazil for
instance you wouldn't want to discover
yourself ground up on the rocks outside
Recife
because your map happened to be 50 miles
off so coordinating time became a
practical matter it also became a
philosophical matter people began to ask
themselves what is time what is space
how could we understand what these
things are so Parker I was the perfect
person to address these sorts of
concerns he thought of himself as a
Polytechnic graduate as somebody who
knew how to move back and forth between
the pure and the applied he talked about
Polytechnique as a Nima's machine an
immense machine that produced students
who were capable of manipulating the
world in certain very practical as well
as theoretical ways in fact once when he
was asked to come back to Polytechnique
to speak to its gratis illustrious
graduates he said what do we have in
common some of us are generals some of
us are captains of industry some of us
are high in government some of us are
sought are mathematicians or physicists
or chemists what is it that we hold in
common all of us
with such diverse paths through life he
said mechanics that's what we have in
common
that's our factory mark that's the stamp
that the factory of Polytechnique has
put upon us it was a theme he came back
to over and over again he thought about
this as he began to because he was
putting became more and more involved
with the Bureau of longitude as he began
to establish a huge machine a machine
that was centered in Paris but drew its
wires over all the oceans down through
to North America to Central America to
South America wires down the coast of
Africa wires into the colonies of
Senegal wires across to North Africa it
was wires that extended all the way to
Haiphong Harbor this was a giant machine
a world covering expanse of wires and
plonker a was at the center of it the
French were also interested in this
electrical technique not just the
Americans and they began to ask
questions sorry I don't that he they
also began to ask questions about these
electrical methods the idea in France
had been that you would take the
observatory where live a be a great
French astronomer and calm you and
others had wired the observatory so that
a signal from the master clock would go
to all the rooms of the observatories
they'd be able to do their work and then
thinking that this was a great triumph
they decided to transform Paris itself
into an immense observatory using the
same techniques that they'd want that
you they used to wire the observatory to
wire the city of Paris they began to
extend these wires to each of the handi
small it was a beautifully designed
system that worked terribly and they
were having great problems with it but
there's one interesting moment in this
history that I think is illustrative of
the difference between the way the
French treated the problem and the
Americans treated the problem the French
who had this beautiful system with the
best astronomer some of the best
astronomers in the world came outside
the train station and then in one letter
that they wrote he said we shouldn't
actually put the wires inside the train
station because if we put clocks that
were coordinated to the observatory
inside the station and something went
wrong we could cause a train wreck
and then we would be in terrible trouble
so what we should do is to surround the
station with clocks beautiful clocks
that are wired to the observatory
the French Trainmen will then set their
clocks looking through the window at
these reflections of the observatory
they'll send the signals down the train
tracks the cities will see the trains
running on time and reflect them and in
a great Versailles like Hall of Mirrors
the time of the observatory of the
French scientists would become the time
of all of France in other words France
would become an extended mirror of the
observatory itself now the Americans in
fact the Americans at my institution had
a rather different picture of how to do
this the first thing they did was to
convert the observatory into a business
and they hired they hired a Yale guy
naturally to come and run this business
which he did with enormous success and
made quite a lot of money selling time
around New England in other words
agreeing to wire up the not only the
watch stores and jewelers but also the
train tracks themselves so that they
would have they were done that Harvard
actually owned telegraph lines and sold
this to to to the to the trains
so rather than convert the country into
an observatory they turned the
observatory into a business and their
goal was right away to run the trains so
as this as things continue with this the
trains became more and more important
the reason that the trains were so
important especially in the United
States is its longitudinal spread as you
know there's several hours difference
between the west coast and the East
Coast and in fact in before the 1880s
there were hundreds of time zones every
crummy little hamlet had its own time
zone and this was fine when people
weren't moving faster than horse speed
between places but as you began to run
trains they needed to have a solution so
they made the train tracks all run on
the time of the big city that ran it so
if the train came out of Chicago it
would all run in Chicago time so the
first
zones where several hundred miles long
and three feet wide and they were set by
Chicago time this worked wonderfully as
long as you had a sort of radial system
but that is you can imagine they started
to cross so now you have two trains
crossing in some town and you have three
times they're at the local time of the
village the time of the origination of
the train track number one and the time
of rigid origination of chain number two
and picture more and more intersections
picture charts like this that have
dozens of times and you can see how
impossible would be if you were trying
to change trains in a station that had
six or seven different times there it
became completely unworkable so the
Train people became interested in
dividing up the zones and there were
debates about how those zones should be
defined some tried to like the Canadian
very ambitious Canadian entrepreneur
Sandford Fleming who also put the beaver
on the first postage stamp of Canada I
couldn't resist that and he designed a
system of what he called cosmic time in
which the whole world would become
divided up into times from a to two
letters short of Z and it would run by
which wherever the earth was between the
center of the earth and the Sun would be
that would be the zone that would
determine the time it was so for
instance G time and everyone would have
these watches that would have a time or
B time so everyone would run on the same
time nobody much liked that idea that
other people wanted national times one
time based on Washington DC in the
United States other people wanted other
time but the train the trains eventually
decided that they wanted the time zones
that roughly speaking that we have now
and as of November 18th 1883 they got
what they wanted after having voted by
miles of track so you got to vote on
this depend if you had five miles of
track you got five votes if you had a
thousand dollars of track got a thousand
votes it was really the trains vote in
some deep sense and they established
this system shortly afterwards there was
a conference where an international
conference the French and the British
had been battling it out as they've
always have been over who would control
the 0 of
longitude and to make a map in other
words who would control the zero time
and the British thought a really great
place to put the zero of time was London
Greenwich Observatory they thought was
perfect natural place who could want
better and the French thought a terrific
place would be Paris so the French knew
they weren't gonna get Paris so they
said well what about the ancient island
of Farah where Ptolemy had put his his
edge of the world and we'll set that as
the zero of longitude and things were
going along not very well but not too
badly until someone at the conference
pointed out that the island of Pharaoh
wasn't actually where the French said it
was the French said it was twenty
degrees west of Paris in fact it wasn't
there but it had been statutorily put
there to make in fact Paris zero just
off by 20 degrees well that put a big
dent in the argument but then the
British started making their arguments
they said 97% of the world shipping uses
British maps and the French delegate
Johnson stood up and said clients you
speak to us of clients this is a matter
for philosophy for universal reason we
should decide this and they said
universal reason dictates that it be at
the intersection of continents for
instance across the Bering Sea which if
you check your globe is as far as you
can get from London and still be on the
planet Earth so the the debate went on
with enormous ferocity the French
arguing for some sort of rational system
the British for supplying their clients
the French suspected and I think they
were quite right that the British had
and the Americans had cut a deal with
some of the smaller countries and that
the British Empire had been able to
dominate through some unfair means the
French wanted a fairer international
coordinated effort of which this may
remind you of something more recently
the British and the Americans won
America's remember had just a year
before adopted a system based on
Greenwich so in a sense the deal was
already done before those international
discussions took place so the French at
the end of the conference said look
we've lost every reasonable vote at this
conference and clients have won out over
philosophy but perhaps you could at
least let us explore the possibility of
finishing that revolutionary rational
project of decimal izing time and the
French and the British said well are you
saying you want us to decimalised time
if it said no we want to explore the
idea of decimal izing times the British
and the Americans said ok go back with
your one victory go back to Paris try to
decimal I cept this is a French
revolutionary clock as you see it goes
from one to ten and so they went back
and had to make a commission a
high-level scientific but politically
savvy commission as to who would go back
and they wrote that a mandate for the
Commission they said go back and find
out why the kilogram and the meters
succeeded but the rationalization of
time failed in the revolution after all
it doesn't make sense to have 60 seconds
in a minute 60 minutes in an hour a
clock with 12 divisions a day with 24 a
month it's just that the whole thing was
crazy from a scientific rational point
of view so put somebody who really
understands these issues in charge and
the man put in charge was pong cray so
Park read before relativity had to deal
with this question of the measure of
time and while he's involved the bureau
of longitude sending out people and they
talk about envy these accounts they sent
that they haven't made built a an
observatory on the cliffs of some
godforsaken island somewhere in the
Pacific and you picture this gilded dome
with people padding around silently in
white smocks this is the kind of
observatory they had in mind it's an 8
foot by 8 foot wooden shack some guy in
a pith helmet and
trying to sight the stars and wired up
to the underwater network of tables and
they were sending back the data that
point cray was getting the so there was
a race on part of it was practical who
would make these maps but part of it was
this symbolic race for Empire that was
taking place in Central America South
America Africa Indochina as everyone the
big colonial powers the in particular
the French the British the Americans
were racing to see who could get their
Maps out who could map in a sense put
the temporal flag at these various sites
it was a world spanning network these
were systems sometimes it had 18,000
miles of cable involved in them at a
time when these little Hut's
were illuminated by oil lamps it's
really quite an extraordinary
technological project when you think of
it one of the projects that was in this
period was wiring up Senegal worth of
where the French were fighting an anti
in an insurrection and insurrection in
in in Senegal by the locals that
continued all the way up through World
War one but one of the so that French
would wire up their cables to try to get
the mapping done and the locals would
cut them down and they were trying to
French trying to build a train between
da car and st. Louis this is the kind of
they used the fort in fact to make these
longitudinal measurements that telegraph
wires had come out of the water go to
the fort and they literally shoot the
stars they take the [ __ ] the big guns
that over looked the the coal yards that
you see up here on the top over the fort
and they would use them to sight on
stars to make their measurements and
compare them with the where the stars
were in Paris at the same time as
determined by telegraphy here's another
fort in st. Louis and then there was one
very interesting expedition with the
French were trying to remap in Ecuador
maketo expedition from Peru Colombia and
they were mapping this you see these
little triangles there literally
triangulated and sending their telegraph
signals
back up to Europe here now one of the
things that's fascinating is in porn
craze great works like science and
hypothesis you see these references to
things that seem like pure science
fiction like imagine that you carry a
ruler and it's changed the temperature
is changing so fast that it's length is
changing before your eyes how would we
know what measure is and in fact at just
that moment quant gray is corresponding
with his his guys in the high Andes and
they're sending back reports saying the
temperature changes by 30 or 40 degrees
here in a matter of minutes our rulers
are changing their lengths in fact time
after time Paco writes very beautifully
about a clouded shrouded planet in which
how would you know that the earth was
turning and he said you could know by by
bobbing a pendulum and then he begins to
explain the rotation of the earth that
way and in fact his guys were stuck up
in the high Andes they'd asked the local
guides can you see when you go up in the
high in the up that mountain and they
said of course we can see because what
they meant they could see the Indians
that lived there they could see to get
up the path but what the French wanted
to do was to see the adjacent peaks so
they could do the triangulation well the
Indians had no need to see the adjacent
peak so these guys spent six months up
there in sub-zero weather having their
tents blown away while they tried to see
the sky for 10 minutes to get a sighting
on the Stars so they were living in that
clouded shrouded planet that Wonka ray
wrote about so again you see this
passage back and forth between the
metaphorical philosophical as Parkway
uses it and this all too real respect
the circumstances that his men are
working through in these expeditions but
Parker is also in addition to running
these longitude shows also very involved
with the physics one of the great
problems was to determine whether
electricity and magnetism as it was
understood in the 19th century was valid
if you were moving after all Maxwell's
great prediction had been that
electromagnet magnetic waves were alight
and that he essentially invented radio
waves and said the light was nothing but
high-frequency radio waves so
waves it was thought had to be waved in
something you couldn't just have a wave
and that something was supposed to be
the ether so people wanted to measure
how fast we were moving in the ether and
Michelson and his colleagues designed
this beautiful apparatus that that was
supposed to determine how fast you were
moving in the ether but to mikaelsons
immense disappointment though he won a
Nobel Prize for it he thought he was a
failure because he never could figure
out how fast we were moving in the ether
the result was always zero so plunk ray
and Lorentz and the other physicists
could all decided that there must be
some very complicated process that
shrank the arms relative to one another
in just a proportion to make it
impossible to detect moving through the
ether Bankrate was also dealing with
this problem of the decimalisation of
time and he began he got his commission
together ships navigators astronomers
railroad magnets physicists and they
said well to decimalised time we really
ought to read avoid the clock maybe we
should divide it into a hundred part the
circle into 100 parts or 200 parts of
400 parts rather than say 360 parts or
maybe 240 parts so each hour would be
divided into ten parts so all these
different techniques and plonker I said
let's be rational let's figure out what
I need the least amount of
multiplication to do if I want to
convert things back and forth using
clocks that are divided in different
numbers of parts well he said if we
divided into four hundred parts we only
have to do single-digit multiplications
for our different operations problems
solved it's the simplest solution that's
how pong Cray liked to think about the
world he said find that which is most
convenient and then adopted and what's
most convenient is objectively
discernible here multiplication by one
digit is simpler than multiplying by two
digits now nobody liked this solution in
the real world so it didn't last long
but it shows you what Quon Cray wanted
from his practical involvement he wanted
something that was convenient simple and
helped us manipulate the world we'll
come back to this he also if you look at
the charts that were being sent back by
his his expeditions and the British
Editions you see that they're worried in
the right hand caramel hard to read it
says time of transmission they're
worried how long it takes to get from
say Paris to Brazil you're now getting
distances like six thousand miles which
even if it went at the speed of light
would be a thirtieth of a second which
begins to be within their error zone so
that if you're coordinating your clocks
maybe you need to set your clock if you
send it at 12:00 not two twelve when it
gets there but two twelve plus a
thirtieth of a second so Cuong cray in
1898 inspired by his work on these
problems begins to say maybe the
philosophy and the technology come
together maybe that what we mean by
simultaneity is nothing other than
signaling from o'clock eight o'clock be
taking into account how long it takes to
get there it had nothing to do with
physics yet Danny gets more involved
with this technology and in December of
1900 he comes to a conference for
Lorentz the greatest theoretical
physicists of the time and realizes
Parker realizes he can reinterpret what
Lorentz had done instead of making a
what simply for Lorentz a kind of
mathematical trick of changing the
variable T time to something else uses
something else just the way if you had
an equation that forex appeared
everywhere you could simply define a new
number Y that's equal to four X and
simplify it well Parker I realized that
what was going on here in what Lorenz
had done was not just a mathematical
trick it actually could be physically
understood if I was trying to signal
somebody else and I was going into the
ether wind then my signal wouldn't go as
fast as it normally would and we'd have
to correct for that and he realized that
what Lorenz had done could be understood
as simply a physical way of to
telegraphers trying to establish
simultaneity but having to deal with the
ether wind I'll come back to the other
parts of that so in a sense what we see
in 1898 is Pronk ray crossing his
technology of telegraphic time with his
philosophical questions about the
meaning of time and then in December of
1900 he sees how to apply that idea that
simultaneity is nothing other than the
exchange of signals between clocks to
rakh one of the fundamental problems of
physics meanwhile there's somebody else
on the case much less well known the
twenty six-year-old unknown patent clerk
second class Albert Einstein and
Einstein who has not been able to land a
job is the opposite of an establishment
figure has alienated every single one of
his teachers he skipped all his lectures
at the ID no such a technician
hochschule in Zurich his teacher
Minkowski when he heard of Einstein's
relativity work said I'm surprised that
that lazy dog came up with that he wrote
to one physicist and told his girlfriend
at the time that he'd show that smart
aleck what was really going on who's
this guy who thinks he's famous because
thinks he's right because he's famous so
Einstein had a rather less respectful
view shall we say of his teachers then
quark Ray was co-authoring papers since
the time he was a teenager with his
teachers who taught at the institution
he had been at and Einstein was working
on these problems he begins his paper
talking about how if you move a magnet
towards a coil or a coil towards a
magnet seems to be the same effect and
yet we have two different explanations
one of them is if you move the magnet
towards the coil we say it creates an
electric field and that moves the charge
around and if we move the coil towards
the magnet well then the charge gets
moved in the magnetic field two
explanations one phenomenon Einstein
said this is no good buddy said to
understand really what's going on our
problem has to do with time and he says
well what do we usually mean by
coordinating clocks what do we mean he
said we have to have something concrete
in mind well he said we could imagine a
central clock sending signals to all the
other clocks and that when they get it
they set their clocks that way but he
said that's a terrible way of proceeding
because the closed clocks will get the
signal sooner than the far clocks and so
the coordination of clocks would depend
on where I put my central clock well he
says simultaneity can't depend on where
I happened to put my central clock
that's arbitrary so he says we need a
better way and his better way was
essentially the same method that Huang
Craig come had come up with namely we
send a signal but we don't set the clock
if I send it at seven
you don't set it to seven when you get
it you said it to seven plus how long it
takes to get there now Einstein came up
through the Swiss system very different
from the French system at the eth the
Polytechnic in Zurich where he had been
trained they had no time for the kind of
preparatory abstract engineering that
Kwang Cray had learned before he went to
the School of Mines they had to get
everything crammed in at once
Switzerland was feeling very behind in
telegraphy and trains in other very
practical measures the 9 salon graduated
also with a degree in electrical
engineering when he finally got work at
the Patent Office he was across the
street from the Baron Tran station which
you see a little hard to see but above
those oblong windows in the front to the
right and left of the train you see
there are these little clocks the train
station is one of the first places in
Switzerland but one of the last places
in Europe to get coordinated time in
fact when the Swiss put coordinated
clocks into Baron it was headline news
in the 1890s revolution in clocks
screamed the headline of the Baron paper
at the center of the system of train
coordination with these beautiful clocks
this one from Baron this one from Berlin
and you could see the visible evidence
of different times on this building in
Geneva where you had Paris time Geneva
time and Baron time on this building
after time was unified that same
building has one clock so coordinating
clocks was really a rather practical
visual way in fact if you go to Baron
today you'll see many of these enormous
clock towers and you could imagine if
you're trying to catch a train and they
all say something different it would be
disturbing coordinated time became
something that was celebrated even at
the big technical fairs where
organizations gathered to talk about
them in the modernity of coordinated
clocks one enthusiast in the head of the
one of the heads of the organization
said that in our age where time is money
people must have the electrical system
not the antiquated time anarchy that had
been formed out of these pulsed systems
of
maduk tubes that they thought
represented nothing but the repellent
past here's where Einstein lived his
Street on the conga sand if you step
outside of his apartment and turn left
towards the Patent Office you're facing
one of Barron's elegant and recently
coordinated clocks walked down the
street underneath this beautiful clock
to the Patent Office and you pass by
this is his was this Joey this is
Einsteins desk at the Patent Office and
the federal parliament which had been
outfitted with dozens of these new
coordinated clocks that were set to the
master clock they were clocks on street
corners like this one on the public
library which now as I say seems very
innocuous but the time was everything
modern in fact Baron Sentra ban was
dotted with these electrical clocks the
time Einstein was there it was a matter
of some enthusiasm Einstein lived
center-right and had to walk up to the
clocks in the uppermost left there where
the Patent Office was Einstein came to
this kind of work rather naturally his
father and his uncle ran an electrical
technical business this is an ad for
their for their wares and they had they
made the devices that measured how much
the consumption of electricity for
example various kinds of a meters and
watt meters and things like that and
also they advertised what they did is
being useful as Electrical clocks so
these kind of technologies and in fact
the Einstein's uncle had numerous
patents on these devices said that
Einstein from a very young age knew
about these technologies here you see
they were even there were dozens of
patents that came through the Patent
Office at this time in fact we can even
know to the nearest 15 minutes the Swiss
being the Swiss when they arrived and in
fact they're even discussion beginning
in as early as 1902 but in the
literature certainly by 1904 for how to
use radio waves to send time signals all
over the world so one day in the midst
of this and I should say 1905 is the
peak year for these patents the highest
year of any time before that and one day
my ensign has been desperately trying to
crack this problem of the
electrodynamics of moving bodies is
walking with his friend in the hills and
he says I know how to solve the problem
time is the problem that we need to
crack and he pointed to a clock tower in
Morey
this one I know cuz there was only one
clock tower in eure that's the
aristocratic annex of Baron and some
tower and Baron I don't know which and
therefore we know we're exactly where he
was because there's only one place where
you can see Marie's clock tower and
central barons clock towers and that's
up in those hills there so he's up in
that hill pointing down and he said
suppose we want to coordinate clocks we
need to send a signal from one to the
other and I should add that this is
about the 15th of May 1905 and he just
moved outside of the coordinated clock
zone of Baron into a place now in the
less attractive parts of Baron and he he
said I know how to do it we need to
coordinate clocks by the exchange of
signals this was a technology after all
that had been in the books this is a
diagram that kind of diagram that patent
officer would have come across all the
time in addition to the patents they
were systems developed for exchanging
these clocks unifying time in a big city
there was even an effort to use the
Eiffel Tower in fact the Eiffel Tower
was slated to be torn down and the
people after the world after the
exposition and they wrote to Park rang
and said can you please save this tower
we the military would really like to
keep it
as an antenna and in fact they wanted to
use an antenna to run to be able to
communicate with their troops in North
Africa but Park Rae had in mind the idea
starting early on to use it as a way of
sending time signals and in fact this is
the system that they developed that went
to the Eiffel Tower in fact here is the
radio station at the base of the Eiffel
Tower which is one of the ways reasons
that we still have an Eiffel Tower today
so Quang crime was involved with this
and he went back and forth between
lecturing on abstract relativity and
working up on the high reaches of the
Eiffel Tower with his crew figuring out
how to make the radio system work to
send time over the world as they got
that developed he then introduced in his
lectures on relativity said suppose you
want to say the signal from by radio
from Paris to Berlin and again he's
talking about a technology that not only
does he know about he's involved in
establishing so we go back to the system
that Feinstein began with where he talks
about this system of sending out time
from a central point that was not what
Einstein sometimes referred to as merely
a question that only a child would ask
what his time would his space this was a
question that everybody from von Moltke
and plunk write the leading scientists
and engineers of Europe are worried
about how do you coordinate time by the
exchange of signals and Einsteins
solution to it come to in part
independently of pong cray and ponk
resolution were ways to crack this
problem that were contributions both to
the practical and the abstract domain in
fact there really isn't a way of
distinguishing between them there is one
solution that pong cry for instance is
publishing in the same month in a
philosophy journal in a Bureau of in the
annals of the Bureau of longitude and in
a physics journal in modern textbooks
that practicality is often lost except
perhaps sometimes when some of the
theorists writing about it have had a
tremendous amount of engineering
involvement like this book by John
Wheeler where it looks very much like
the kind of practical machine that
Einstein had been involved with so what
for Lorentz had been merely a change of
variables abstract mathematical trick
for pork or a beating against the ether
wind and for Einstein simply the way
nature was you have three different ways
of understanding the exchange of signals
but all of them addressing the central
problem of how to crack the problem of
time by the exchange of signals let me
then conclude in April of 1953 two years
before his death
Einstein wrote from Princeton - Maurice
olivine of the laughter and insight of
their so uh NACA demmick Academy during
Einstein's baron years when this when
the several of them had met over wine
and cheese if they had enough money to
discuss patents physics and philosophy
side by side and in this April 1953 note
he wrote to his friends to the immortal
Olympia Academy in your short act of
existence you took a childish delight in
all that was clear and reasonable your
members created you to amuse themselves
at the expense of your big sisters who
were older and puffed up with pride
fully to appreciate just how far the
members had threw you hit upon the true
through careful observation lasting for
many long years we three members at
least remain steadfast though somewhat
decrepit we still follow the solitary
path of our life by your pure and
inspiring light for you did not grow old
and shapeless along with your members
like a plant that goes to seed to you I
swear fidelity until my last learned
breath from one who hereafter will be
only a corresponding member kec4 the
turn of the century wonk ray inhabited
the Parisian Academy of Arts and
Sciences Einstein the Olympia non
Academy in fact Einstein and Pont Cray
who each have one of the largest
scientific correspondence in the history
of all science never wrote a single
postcard to each other in fact they only
met once towards the end of pong karez
life in 1913 at a conference and one
person Louie Dubrow overheard their
conversation in pong Cray who was
willing to change everything to
introduce chaos into the world and
nonetheless was not willing to go where
Einstein had gone in physics eine spark
ray had said we may need a new mechanics
and by that he meant to
systematic well-formulated system that
allowed you to visualize what was
happening in the world to map it so to
speak to his his one of his nephews said
to map every white space on the globe
and he said to Einstein to this young
scientist so Einstein what mechanics are
you using remember this is the Einstein
who said that mechanics was the factory
stamp of Ecole Polytechnique mechanics
is what holds together the elite of
France and Einstein turned to him and
said Ron Kray no mechanics and Luigi
Brewer says Ron Kray looked puzzled
he must have been more than puzzled
because the next day he got up and he
said that what Einstein had done in
quantum physics threatened through
contradiction to destroy all of science
to become a contradiction an
incomprehensible mess make a
incomprehensible mess of all that was
solid in scientific knowledge and then
an interesting twist the two of them
went home
Einstein wrote to a friend that he'd met
Wonka and Lawrence and Lorentz was
someone he really loved who understood
what was happening but plunk rate
despite his greatness Einstein said
understood nothing wonk ray on the other
hand wrote a letter of recommendation
for Einstein and said that if this young
man has many new clue ideas if even a
single one of them proves to be right he
will be remembered as one of the
greatest scientists of all time
on March 15 1955 Michele Besso died it
was with betho that Einstein did so
productively spoken in the weeks and
months before he came upon the
coordination of clocks as the key to
finishing his work on special relativity
Einstein wrote to Bess's family on the
21st closing his letter with the final
reference to those conversations and to
the perspectival nature of time that
emerged from relativity it was the
Patent Office that reunited us after
Zurich Einstein told besos family our
conversations on the way home had an
incomparable charm It was as if the
all-too-human
did not exist at all now he has taken
leave of this strange world a little
before me this means nothing for us
devout physicists the division between
past present and future is only an
illusion if a stubborn one long after
Einsteins own learned breath a few weeks
later the struggle continued among
many competing interpretations of the
regulated coordination of clocks
synchronized time remained hyper
symbolized never emerging from
contestation among imperial empire
democracy world citizenship anti
anarchism what all these symbols held in
common was a sense that each clock might
signify the individual so that clock
coordination could come to stand in for
a logic of linkage among people's that
was always flickering between the
literal and the metaphorical precisely
because it was abstract concrete or
perhaps concretely abstract the project
of time coordination for towns regions
countries and eventually the globe
became one of the defining structures of
modernity the synchrony of clocks
remains in his ex trickable mix of
social history cultural history
intellectual history technics philosophy
and physics over the last thirty years
it has become a commonplace to pit
bottom up against top-down explanations
neither will do in accounting for time a
medieval saying aimed at capturing the
links between alchemy and astronomy put
it this way in looking down we see up in
looking up we see down that vision of
knowledge serves as well from looking
down to the electromagnetically
regulated clock networks we see up to
images of empire metaphysics and civil
society and looking up to the philosophy
of Einstein and Wonka's procedural
definitions of time space and
simultaneity we see down to the wires
gears and pulses passing through the
barren office and the Paris Bureau of
longitude we find metaphysics in
machines and machines in metaphysics
modernity just in time thank you
if you say it into this microphone
yeah you have to go over there alright
so you you've really laid down great how
Einstein sort of work as a patent clerk
trying to synchronize clock set up his
the foundations of his ideas for special
relativity is there anything like that
to set up his sort of out-weird
explanation or his groundbreaking
explanation of the photoelectric effect
at the same time that's an interesting
question so the question restated is
Einstein in 1905 wrote several crucial
papers he wrote a paper that begins the
idea of what becomes the quantum the
quantum of light that is this paper on
what's called the photoelectric effect
he introduces a paper on Brownian motion
which gave very visible evidence of the
materiality of atoms he did a special
relativity paper and then all that was
in the same volume of the annals of
physics and then in the next volume same
year he published that little equation e
equals MC squared it was a good year so
the question is are the other aspects of
Einsteins work so amenable to being tied
back and forth between the literal and
abstract
I don't know away with the photoelectric
effect to do it quite that way but there
is an example that I think is quite
interesting and that another example is
quite interesting and that is Einstein
was always interested in unifying things
he once said and someone said how come
you have no shampoo and different kinds
of soap he said one soap that ought to
be enough
he thought two kinds of mass that Newton
had the kind of mass that his
gravitational mass how heavy something
is and how hard something is to get
moving inertial mass with one too many
masses and you should bring them
together and that's what his general
theory of relativity does but he also
thought in a very practical way about
magnetism he said look there two kinds
of magnetism there is electromagnetism
you take a piece of wire and you coil it
up attached it to a battery makes a
magnet and then they're permanent
magnets
piece of iron that's magnetized and he
said there can't be two kinds of
magnetism maybe permanent magnets are
just tiny little electromagnets inside
little and then maybe in fact each atom
with its electron going around it is
just a little electromagnet and that in
a in a permanent magnet they just
they're all oriented together and he in
fact designed an experiment and did the
first showed before I for anybody that
experimentally that there was something
to this idea now if you look at what
Einstein was doing there he was actually
working in he was involved in litigation
about a device called a gyro compass
with nuke on new airplanes
this is 1915 and MIT and electric but
and boats that had a lot of electricity
on the metal boats people playing around
the submarines going to the North Pole
places where magnetic compasses don't
work they needed some sort of gyroscope
to act as a compass and there was a suit
between a German inventor called on
shoots and Sperry Elmer Sperry of Sperry
Rand the big company and spray granted
not to put too fine a point on it stolen
the idea of on shoes now when you're
accused of having ripped off a patent
from somebody the standard strategy is
to say oh no no I didn't steal it from a
it's been long known and if you go back
into the annals of history of patents
you can see lots of examples of this
side and stealin but not only dine steal
it the guy that is accusing me didn't
invent it so Sperry tried this and
Einstein was called in as an expert
witness now most of the patents that
Einstein worked on were destroyed
because 20 years after a patent is filed
the opinions are destroyed now in 1925
Einstein was the most famous scientist
on the planet but the Swiss or the Swiss
and you know the day came and they fired
up the shredders and threatened whatever
this was did in those days anyway so
they shredded these documents but there
were certain documents that were
preserved anything that had been in
litigation was preserved and because
Einstein had been an expert witness all
of this opinion you know his what he
wrote was there and you could see that
he got involved with this case and
became such an expert on trial compasses
that he took out a
own patents and collected royalties on
it for decades now after he did this
work he turned around and he said wait a
second
maybe the atom is just a tiny gyroscope
and he built this experiment on the idea
that a permanent magnet was made of a
lot of little gyroscopes and if you
could orient them then suddenly that's
the magnet would start to rotate and he
did the experiment you showed it to be
so and he convinced himself that this
was the source of the magnetism so there
is an example we're totally explicitly
we know that Einsteins work in the
Patent Office led to his idea of taking
the atom to be simultaneously a
mechanical gyroscope and the source of
permanent magnetism
I should add just one last thing here
this is a this is the the GPS system
which is interesting for two reasons
one is that it uses Einstein's theory of
special relativity in fact it uses
Einstein's general theory of relativity
in fact if Einstein's theory of
relativity was wrong
everything from smart bombs to rental
cars would start going off course in a
dramatic way by several miles in a
couple of minutes in fact when they
launched the first GPS satellites the
engineers said what do you mean we have
to put in a correction for general
relativity we refused and the physicists
said no no you have you have to put it
in and they said no we're not going to
put it in so they compromised and they
put it in the satellite such they could
turn it on from Houston or whichever the
base was controlling it and they put it
up clocks start to run late as predicted
and so the engineers say okay well we'll
admit that in fact this is 1970s that
general relativity might have something
to to it it turned it on and they've run
with general relativity ever since now
also this when they set up these
satellites since they were going to be
used for military means that was their
first application there was a terror
group that came in and went and broke
into the Rockwell plant ins in Steele
Beach California and they smashed the
satellite
and they they named themselves after the
Terminator movies and and it's sort of a
play between science fiction and
anti-military stick action broke up some
satellites but this is an old story in
some ways one of the great
Conrad stories the secret agents is
about as based on a true incident where
a French terrorist had gone in men and
bowed out and tried to blow up Greenwich
Observatory to destroy the center of
time but unfortunately his cocktail
detonated in Greenwich Park and he
unfortunately by fortunately for him it
detonated on him in the park in front of
in front of the observatory other
questions and here's an en I'll just end
with which I find very amusing I want
there's a German company that makes
coordinated clocks that you can buy and
they get their radio signal from
Colorado and I saw this ad that says the
US government always knows exactly what
time it is do you
sorry I wondered about the cultural uses
of coordinated time and what that meant
and I thought on German company I wonder
if they say in Germany the German
government knows what time it is do and
if you look it up no they don't so it's
clear that coordinated time even today
means something different in one country
than another all right thank you very
much
Einstein's clocks Wonka raised maps is
published by WW Norton & Company visit
wwm for more information
next week on history on book TV the
great influenza John Barry